l' angoisse de tomber malade des années
après avoir exercé leur travail c'est le
cauchemar quotidien que vivent
huit salariés de tours métropole pendant
les années 2000 ses employés du service
des eaux ont travaillé sans le savoir
sur deux îles de la loire contaminés à
l'amiante
ils ont porté plainte pour préjudice
d'anxiété la fer était jugée aujourd'hui
au tribunal administratif d'orléans lui
cachent pas ils vivent avec la peur au
ventre
huit fonctionnaires et ex fonctionnaire
du service des eaux de la métropole de
tours ont fait face à leur employeur ce
matin au tribunal administratif
d'orléans
leur but être reconnus comme des
victimes
après avoir travaillé sans protection
sur les sols pollués par l'amiante de
l'île aucard et de l'île aux vaches
entre 2000 et 2012 parmi eux michel le
berre pendant plusieurs années il a
tendu la pelouse des îles se retrouvant
au quotidien couvert de poussière
d'amiante de la tête aux pieds
aujourd'hui l'homme vite avec une épée
de damoclès au-dessus de la tête
j'ai trois nodule au poumon gauche et un
quatrième jeu suivant je me suis fait
enlever qui étaient là bon pour
l'instant d'après on a vu que c'était
pas de chez eux mais vous qu'on m'a dit
pour poster éclate alors vous avez tous
les matins quand je me lève dans ma tête
ça tourne je vous avais peur tous les
jours voilà bien sûr s'enticha mais
voilà au début des années 2000 plusieurs
puits construits avec de l'amiante sont
démantelés sur les îles mais les gravats
sont finalement éparpillés au sol
en tout ce sont deux mille mètres cubes
de l'île aucard et 11000 mètres cubes de
l'île aux vaches qui seront polluer sans
que les personnes qui y travaillent n'en
soit averti à l'époque des faits c'est
la mairie de tours qui est en charge des
eaux une compétence transférée à la
métropole en 2010 est désormais l'avocat
des huit requérants demandent aux deux
collectivités territoriales de verser 30
mille euros à chaque victime
au nom du préjudice d'anxiété nous
demandons donc la réparation du
préjudice d'anxiété subi par ces agents
de
deux tours qui ont été exposés à
l'amiante et qui ont un risque
malheureusement de survenance d'une
pathologie grave
malheureusement l'un d'entre eux est
décédé d'une maladie de l'amiante donc
cette inquiétude à les justifier
et c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
action a été engagée
la décision du tribunal administratif
d'orléans a été mise en délibéré le
jugement sera rendu le 18 mai prochain